je vais vous le chemin de bush on le
bouge faire le moins de faire mouche
dans le bush pendant le dîner l
interview dernier coup geneviève de
fontenay vient en commentant sa console
un lien comme disait bien geneviève dans
les coups durs
si tu réponds un centre et il va te dire
dernier comme vous je dis ce que tu fais
ce que tu veux dire non dernier coup dur
précieusement dernier coup dur
votre dernier coup dur moi oui ça va
très bien voilà je ne vienne n'a pas de
coup dur dernier coup de tête à temps
dernier coup de coeur c'est la présente
une petite appréhension
twilight et c'est une session
l'hippodrome de deauville nous avons
peut-être apple ça fait plaisir du
nouveau levé nous avons nous avons
apporté un peu de joie à des enfants
trisomiques qui regardent et miss france
avec beaucoup d'émotion il y en a plein
les centres ares mois d'août dernier
coup de foudre c'est vous mon chat
phoque
dernier coup de gueule ce soir je viens
vous savez ce qu'on va faire maintenant
on va planter michael au blind test